il est 12h45 bonjour bienvenue sur le
figarolive dans quelques minutes le
président de la République s'adressera
aux Français il fut un temps où on le
voyait beaucoup le président lorsqu'il
regardait les Français droit dans les
yeux à travers l'écran du poste de
télévision pour dire nous sommes en
guerre oui c'était l'époque du covid
mais depuis quelques mois le président
se fait discret préfère les sujets
internationaux et c'est pourquoi
l'interview qu'il donne dans quelques
minutes est un événement bonjour
Guillaume Rocket bonjour Thibault
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
Magazine Guillaume c'est interview un
petit événement quand même ouais c'est
même un grand événement je pense que
c'est un moment important pas forcément
par le message que va délivrer le
président de la République qui va pas
nécessairement renverser la table
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale
démissionner mais il y a peu de chance
j'y crois pas trop mais on pourra y
revenir si vous voulez en revanche c'est
un c'est un moment important parce que
nous sommes dans une situation inédite
sous la Cinquième République
c'est-à-dire que le Président de la
République est
presque entravé pour ensuite de son
mandat il a réussi dans la douleur à
faire passer cette réforme des retraites
mais on sent bien qu'il lui manque non
seulement une majorité solide mais ça
c'est pas nouveau ça date de juin
dernier au moment de des législatives ou
les Français n'ont pas voulu donner aux
parties du président une majorité stable
et suffisante mais aussi il y a une
questionnement un questionnement sur la
légitimité non pas politique d'Emmanuel
Macron qui est président de la
République son rapport à l'état son
rapport plutôt aux Français on voit bien
que quelque chose s'est cassé pendant
pendant cette réforme et comment est-ce
que le Président de la République va
pouvoir recoudre ce lien c'est un moment
important ce choix de l'interview à 13h
vous y attendiez déjà ce qu'il donne une
interview qu'il prenne la parole et
ensuite ce choix l'interview à 13h ça
c'est pas anodin alors je crois que je
vais changer de métier parce que je ne
m'attendais ni à l'interview aussi vite
ni à 13h bon donc
vous êtes quand même là pour en parler
je pensais que
Emmanuel Macron allait attendre le
moment social important de demain avec
cette journée de mobilisation pour voir
un petit peu en fonction de de
l'importance des du mouvement social
calibré sa réponse mais non il s'agit il
choisit de parler avant et puis
effectivement ce trésor c'est un peu
bizarre en général quand on a quelque
chose d'important à dire aux Français on
le fait à 20h parce que c'est là c'est
là où il y a le plus de monde donc
est-ce que ça signifie que le chef de
l'État s'apprête à délivrer un message
un peu à à bas prix à bas bruit pardon
c'est comme si il disait je parle mais
je ne veux pas parler trop fort mais 13h
alors il se dit que ce serait pour
parler aux régions à la province
pourquoi en région en province on à 13h
on est devant sa télé alors ça c'est
assez drôle oui je crois que ça relève
un petit peu du cliché les gens qui
retournent
déjeuner chez eux en province même si
c'est vrai que les temps de transport
sont moins long il y a aussi une
structure d'audience de ce journal de
13h qui fait que
il y a et pour cause un nombre important
de personnes inactives qui regardent je
crois que la moyenne d'âge sur France 2
de 56 ou 57 ans et sur TF1 61 ans
exactement et or on sait que
le cœur du soutien à cette réforme des
retraites bah c'est justement les
retraités parce que comme ils
travaillent plus elle les dérange pas
trop que les autres doivent bosser de
nous en plus bon on le voit c'est peu
Emmanuel Macron sur cette question des
retraites non pourquoi il a fait c'est
un choix complètement mesuré il l'a pris
cette décision ou finalement il avait
pas d'autres options il fallait laisser
faire le gouvernement je pense que c'est
un choix c'est-à-dire que il avait
annoncé clairement pendant sa campagne
pour sa réélection qu'il allait mettre
en oeuvre cette réforme des retraites
ensuite il a laissé faire son
gouvernement et Elisabeth borne pour
deux raisons une raison technique qui
est que il fallait trouver une majorité
à l'Assemblée et ça c'est vraiment dans
le boulot du Premier ministre parce que
le Président il est pas bienvenu à
l'Assemblée
et puis c'est quand même pas le la la le
fondement de sa mission que de que
d'appeler les chefs de partie les gens
influents chez LR en disant allez sois
sympa à votre malware donc c'est plutôt
du nouveau gouvernemental et puis il y a
une raison politique aussi à cette mise
en retrait qui est que Elisabeth borne a
joué le rôle traditionnel du Premier
ministre sous l'assani République
c'est-à-dire de servir de d'écran au
président comment on dit dans l'armée
passe devant je te couvre 12h50 dans 10
minutes le président de la République
s'adressera aux Français dans une
interview que vous suivez évidemment sur
le Figaro live est-ce que justement le
fait de se mettre en retrait de
s'intéresser plutôt aux questions
internationales de se désintéresser
d'une certaine manière des
préoccupations des Français des sujets
du quotidien à créer cette scission
cette rupture dont vous parliez en
ouverture de Live non je pense pas je
pense que dès le départ il y avait
un désaccord d'une majorité de Français
est plus encore du mouvement syndical
avec cette réforme donc le désaccord il
était sur le fond les gens on peut les
comprendre non pas envie de travailler
davantage et je pense que si Emmanuel
Macron avait fait 5 discours de plus sur
le sujet ça n'aurait rien changé donc
c'est un désaccord de fond et ce qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que si le
chef de l'État pensait se protéger entre
guillemets en intervenant peu ça a été
un échec
relatif parce qu'on voit bien que dans
l'opinion aujourd'hui quand on entend
les gens qui manifestent c'est à
Emmanuel Macron qu'ils en veulent c'est
pas exactement on l'a vu sur les
affiches c'est toujours Emmanuel Macron
qui est ciblé la situation elle est
assez complexe on a l'impression qu'il
qu'il est dans une impasse 100 lettres
je veux dire il y a des manifestations
mais ça réforme est passé elle est
arrivée au bout de son parcours
démocratique même si certains le
remettent en cause
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire bon voilà le
jeu politique c'est fait cette loi est
passée bon c'est vrai que vous avez
raison on est dans une situation un peu
un peu un peu flottante un peu gazeuse
qui est le reflet de la situation
institutionnelle on a d'un côté un
président de la République qui a
beaucoup de pouvoir c'est la cinquième
république qui veut ça il a été élu
confortablement face à Marine Le Pen
mais il n'a pas de majorité pour
gouverner et donc il faut qu'il se
trouve un chemin moi ce que je pense
c'est qu'il va faire aujourd'hui un peu
l'essuie-glace c'est à dire que après
avoir dit on ne lâche rien sur les
retraites on fait passer la loi même par
le 49-3 il va dire bon maintenant le
moment est venu de mesure plus
consensuelles on met de côté ce qui peut
fâcher mais
en même temps va exploser à nouveau
grand jour je pense je pense parce que
en fait c'est Emmanuel Macron c'est ça
c'est que c'est pas c'est pas un homme
qui renverse la table
finalement non non il est il est il est
très consensuel on voit bien d'ailleurs
que quand il est en situation difficile
il met toujours du temps à à réagir
je pense qu'il a très peur de revoir une
séquence de type gilet jaune donc je
pense qu'il va il va jouer l'apaisement
et puis il espère que
à l'avenir il puisse continuer
vaille que vaille avec cette attelage
bizarre d'une majorité qui n'est pas là
mais vous savez moi je pense que c'est
pas la fin du monde cette histoire je
partage pas le diagnostic peut-être que
je me trompe avec les jours prochains
vont me donner tort mais des gens qui
sont catastrophes en disant il y a eu
une déchirure avec le pays il ne s'en
remettra pas regardez ce qui s'est passé
à l'Assemblée ça a quand même été très
violent bon les il y a des mois depuis
deux mois exactement le ministre
contrainte d'assassin la France
insoumise qui a bordélisé le truc comme
jamais et on s'est dit il se remettront
pas qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier il y
a un projet de loi qui a été voté c'est
passé un peu inaperçu le projet de loi
sur le sur la relance du nucléaire à
trouver vous voyez même vous qui suivez
ça de près et je vous conseille le site
du Figaro qui est très bien fait parce
que c'est pas vrai et ils en ont ils en
ont parlé il y a une loi donc pour
relancer le programme nucléaire civil
qui a été voté grâce à la majorité
relative celle de de renaissance mais
aussi grâce aux voies du rassemblement
national et on voit de LR donc des
communistes aussi et les communistes
absolument pas comme vous voyez que vous
avez ce sujet c'était un piège et donc
c'est intéressant de voir que et ben
malgré ses difficultés malgré le 49.3
malgré la le tiers des LR qui a fait ses
sessions on peut encore trouver des
majorités donc le truc est pas foutu bon
il va prendre la parole Emmanuel Macron
dans 6 minutes maintenant à quoi ça sert
les Français qui manifestent on a vu les
images et quelques instants hier soir ce
matin la garde Toulouse bloquée à Rennes
les pêcheurs qui manifestent partout en
France plusieurs points de blocage on
peut se dire à 13h30 ah bon d'accord bon
on arrête là le président a parlé
ça ne doit pas se passer comme ça non ça
se passera sans doute pas comme ça
il faut bien voir que ces mouvements
sont extrêmement minoritaires on n'est
pas en mai 68 d'abord le pays n'est pas
bloqué alors évidemment demain il y aura
des des perturbations fortes dans les
transports mais ce n'est pas du tout la
grève générale il y a pas de mouvement
de de blocage massif on voit des petits
rassemblements sporadiques avec des gens
qui sont plutôt calmes mais il y a
toujours des voyous d'extrême gauche qui
viennent se greffer là-dessus pour aller
[__] le bazar et et les images de la
République envoyer les images de la
place en hauteur pas énormément de monde
et des gens qui étaient là étaient venus
essentiellement pour le conflit voilà et
il faut il faut se méfier de l'effet de
loupe notre métier c'est de c'est de
parler de ce qui bouge ou de ce qui
flambe mais ce n'est pas le pays qui est
en train de flamber donc
encore une fois là pour le coup je fais
pas de pronostic ça sera intéressant de
voir quelle est la mobilisation de
est-ce que les gens se disent ok de
toute façon même si on n'était pas
d'accord cette loi est passée donc on se
résigne moi c'est plutôt ce que je pense
ou alors
Emmanuel Macron a créé une espèce de de
allumer la mèche d'une exposition
sociale qui serait inédite dans le
depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir
puisque le mouvement des gilets jaunes
était très différent ça n'était pas la
même la même les mêmes ressorts et
c'était pas les mêmes populations 4
minutes avant l'interview du président
de la République vous suivez évidemment
sur Le Figaro.fr sur sur Youtube c'est
de savoir ce que peut dire le président
lors de cette interview cette phrase
rapportée Emmanuel Macron la foule n'a
pas de légitimité face au peuple qui
s'exprime à travers ses élus il y a pas
vraiment envie d'éteindre le feu là le
président de la République non c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une part de
provocation
chez Emmanuel Macron avec cette phrase
sur le fond ce qui dit n'est pas faux
c'est vrai que en France sauf quand on
fait appel au référendum le peuple
s'exprime à travers ses représentants
qui sont les parlementaires et il y a
pas eu de majorité de députés pour voter
la censure et donc pour s'opposer à
cette loi donc elle est supposée être
actée ce qui est intéressant c'est que
Emmanuel Macron dans une opposition
assez classique
distingue bien la foule du peuple il y a
cette belle phrase de Victor Hugo
parfois la foule trahit le peuple
c'est-à-dire de dire que le message
subliminal c'est de dire ok les Français
sont contre cette mesure mais finalement
ils savent bien qu'il y a pas
d'alternative et que de toute façon il
faudra travailler plus longtemps parce
que on vit plus longtemps et de ce fait
il ne faut pas surestimer l'importance
de ces de ces mouvements de foule
justement qui font la une des chaînes
d'infos et de notre site depuis
plusieurs jours il y a plein d'options
on parle d'émissions du gouvernement
forcée dans remaniement une dissolution
d'un référendum pourtant il a l'air de
vouloir choisir aucune option à Emmanuel
Macron tout ça c'est écarté pour
l'instant non oui définitivement d'abord
ce serait pas la première fois les
manuel Macron n'aime pas réagir sous la
pression et puis il avait fait lors de
manifestations de gilets jaunes quand
même oui il avait fait mais c'était
il y avait une pression presque parce
que physique contre lui vous souvenez
c'était voilà les alentours du quartier
de l'Élysée
cerner le cerner l'Élysée mais là cette
loi a été votée
Elisabeth borne est allé jusqu'à dire
que c'était une forme de victoire pour
le gouvernement c'est vrai que il n'a
pas cédé il est là en président
réformateur les retraites c'est quand
même la mesure symbolique donc si je
sais pas ce qu'il va faire mais renvoyer
Elisabeth borne changer le gouvernement
ce serait une façon de dire ok je me
suis trompé j'ai eu tort donc finalement
je rebat les cartes mais le statu quo
est possible avec ce qu'on voit dans la
rue avec cette colère qui ne s'est pas
manifester autant que l'esprit est
certain dans les rues avec ses sondages
qui sont contre la réforme des retraites
avec un mandat à finir et à finir à
continuer parce qu'on est encore loin de
la fin il peut se contenter de ne rien
faire Emmanuel Macron oui je pense qu'il
le peut il peut annoncer des mesures
semble-t-il par exemple le report de la
loi sur l'immigration qui
suscitaient des polémiques au sein même
de sa majorité mais
oui il peut d'abord ne pas tenir compte
des sondages parce que il est là pour 5
ans donc que cette mesure soit un
populaire ça n'est pas surprenant mais
Emmanuel Macron n'oublie pas que dès
2017 il avait été élu pour transformer
le pays c'est ça son programme c'est
passé un homme qui a pas d'idéologie
particulière il est pas conservateur
c'est un moderne c'est un modernisateur
de dire ben voilà il faut travailler
plus vous êtes pas moderne moi j'aime
bien travailler mais je pense qu'il fait
il y a quelques quelques valeurs sur
lesquelles il faut pas transiger je suis
pas sûr qu'on soit Emmanuel Macron et
moi sur la même ligne mais je sais pas
vraiment le sujet du jour en revanche je
pense que oui il n'a pas intérêt
aujourd'hui à donner le sentiment
d'avoir commis une faute ou de s'être
trompé par des des mesures qui
apparaîtraient comme des recules il est
13h le président de la République doit
s'exprimer d'un instant à l'autre
puisqu'il est interviewé par nos
confrères de TF1 et France 2 l'interview
commence on se retrouve tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup Guillaume Rocket de nous
recevoir à l'Elysée avec Julian Bugier
bonjour Julian bonjour Marie-Sophie
bonjour monsieur le Président vous savez
que votre parole aujourd'hui est
particulièrement attendue c'est la toute
première fois que vous vous exprimez
depuis le recours au 49.3 et depuis que
cette réforme des retraites a été
adoptée par le Parlement elle est très
contestée dans la rue première question
donc est-ce que ce texte entrera en
application comme prévu au 1er septembre
bonjour et bienvenue je suis heureux de
pouvoir en effet répondre à vos
questions écoutez ce texte il va
poursuivre son chemin démocratique
et a été préparé par le gouvernement
après des mois de concertation il a été
ensuite porté par le gouvernement qu'il
a modifié après ses concertations au
Parlement il a donné lieu à 175 heures
de débat
c'est le texte
issu du chemin parlementaire enrichi par
le parlementaire qui a été adopté dans
la commission mixte paritaire puis voté
par le Sénat et en effet qui a été
adopté par l'Assemblée suite à
l'utilisation de l'article 109.3 et donc
par un vote si on ne censure contre le
gouvernement qui a échoué il est
aujourd'hui devant le Conseil
constitutionnel et donc il faut
maintenant attendre que le Conseil
constitutionnel se prononce et c'est à
l'issue de cette décision que j'aurais
promulgué un texte et donc il permettra
de faire évoluer les choses pour vous
créer du premier septembre tenez-vous à
cette date je pense que pour que les
choses rentrent en place à la fois pour
que d'ici à la fin de l'année
pour près de 2 millions de nos
compatriotes un million 800 000
exactement et puis savoir leur pension
qui commence à être augmentée environ
600 euros par an en moyenne pour ces 1
million 8 pour que en effet on commence
à décaler l'âge légal de 3 mois par an
progressivement et qu'on accélère les
l'augmentation du nombre de trimestres à
travailler jusqu'à 43 ans à horizon 2027
et bien il faut que ça rentre en vigueur
d'ici à la fin de l'année mais
maintenant au moment où je vous parle il
faut attendre la décision du Conseil
alors on va parler de la crise sociale
dans notre pays qui est fort on va
parler de la crise politique évidemment
l'Assemblée nationale et de ce qui s'est
passé d'abord je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur des propos que vous avez
tenus qui ont pu choquer certains
c'était hier devant les parlementaires
vous avez dit la foule n'a pas de
légitimité face au peuple qui s'exprime
à travers les élus et ça dire à vos yeux
que le mécontentement qui s'exprime dans
les rues aujourd'hui les manifestants
sont illégitimes non pas du tout et
merci de me permettre de clarifier cela
parce que j'ai des choses hier précises
à des parlementaires qui ont subi des
agressions inacceptables depuis ces
derniers jours
et je vous le dis ici avec beaucoup de
solennité nous sommes une grande nation
et un vieux peuple
il se dotent de responsable qui ont une
légitimité politique président de la
République des parlementaires sont élus
par lui il y a des légitimités qui
existent les syndicats ont une
légitimité quand ils défilent qu'ils
manifeste ils sont en opposition à cette
réforme je les respecte il défendent
leur point de vue et d'ailleurs ces
protégé par la Constitution le droit de
manifester pétition il y a légitimité et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement comme le
Parlement a essayé de tenir compte de
ces manifestations et d'intégrer une
partie de ces on y reviendra à côté de
ça non à côté de ça je vous le dis dans
le moment que vivent nos démocraties
quand des groupes utilisent l'extrême
violence pour agresser des élus de la
République qu'il soit parlementaires
aujourd'hui ou maire malheureusement
chaque semaine quand ils utilisent la
violence
sans règle absolue parce qu'ils ne sont
pas contents de quelque chose alors là
ça n'est plus la démocratie
ce sont des propos qui clarifient quand
les États-Unis d'Amérique ont vécu ce
qu'ils ont vécu au Capitole quand le
Brésil a vécu ce qu'il a vécu quand vous
avez eu l'extrême violence en Allemagne
au Pays-Bas ou parfois par le passé chez
nous je vous le dit très nettement il
faut dire on respecte on écoute on
essaie d'avancer pour le pays et je vais
y revenir parce que je veux qu'on parle
de cette réforme mais on ne peut
accepter
ni les factions ni les factions
il faut les écouter il faut écouter
leurs colères et y répondre c'est cela
parce qu'avec ces propos vous faites
référence au débordement mais que
dites-vous à ceux qui vont manifester
demain 9e journée d'action dans la rue
c'est quoi c'est pas la peine d'y aller
il n'y a plus rien à négocier
alors je voudrais essayer de
te dire d'abord ce que ce texte va faire
et pourquoi on l'a fait vous savez au
moment où je vous parle est-ce que vous
pensez que ça me fait plaisir de faire
cette réforme dites-le nous non est-ce
que vous pensez que j'aurais pas pu
faire comme tente avant moi mettre la
poussière sous le tapis oui peut-être
mais la réalité est si il y a une chose
que je regrette c'est que nous n'avons
pas réussi à partager la contrainte plus
exactement la nécessité de faire cette
réforme au moment moi je suis rentré
dans la vie active il y avait 10
millions de retraités il y en a
aujourd'hui 17 millions dans les années
2030 il y en aura 20 millions
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
continuer avec
les mêmes règles on rentre de plus en
plus tard dans la vie professionnelle on
vit et c'est une chance de plus en plus
tard nous avons un système par
répartition qui fait que c'est nous les
actifs qui finançons aujourd'hui les
retraites on finance pas les nôtres
[Musique]
donc oui il y a pas 36 solutions si on
veut que le régime soit équilibré il ne
l'est plus et plus on va attendre plus
il se dégrada donc cette réforme elle
est nécessaire et je le dis aux Français
ça ne me fait pas plaisir j'aurais voulu
ne pas la faire mais c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai pris l'engagement de l'affaire
devant vous par le sens des
responsabilités et c'est l'intérêt
général qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire face
à cette situation démographique qui est
la nôtre on aurait pu dire on baisse les
pensions la réponse est non ne retraités
n'ont pas trop de pouvoir d'achat on
peut pas baisser leur pension on va même
relever celle des plus modestes la
deuxième solution ça aurait été
d'augmenter les cotisations des actifs
nous avons un problème de pouvoir
d'achat en raison de l'inflation des
entreprises monsieur le Président et de
mettre les entreprises à contribution ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui dans le
financement non parce que je vais venir
c'est pas comme ça qui marche les
retraites les retraites c'est des
cotisations des actifs pour les
retraités la troisième solution c'est de
dire au fond j'acte que mon système de
retraite a un déséquilibre et c'est le
budget de l'État qui va le financer par
ailleurs et alors comment on fait quand
c'est le budget de l'État soit on
augmente les impôts nous sommes l'un des
pays
occidentaux qui a les impôts les plus
hauts moi je crois dans la
réindustrialisation du pays j'espère
qu'on y reviendra on la défendu on est
en train de gagner cette bataille c'est
pas pour faire l'inverse
deuxièmement on pourrait dire c'est aux
dépens de priorité on doit investir dans
nos services publics notre école notre
santé on peut pas prendre cet argent
pour le mettre sur les retraites alors
la formule magique qui est implicitement
le projet de toutes les oppositions et
de tout ce qui s'opposent à cette
réforme c'est le déficit
mais qu'est-ce que c'est le déficit ça
veut dire de fait que vous choisissez de
faire payer vos enfants parce que
aujourd'hui vous refusez de décider avec
l'arté courage regardez ce collègues du
parisien avait fait cette petite
infographie j'ai arrivé de la convoquer
enfin nous sommes le pays d'Europe qui
avec la Suède qui a un autre système et
un autre modèle maisons ensemble
regardez tous les autres sont entre 65
et 60 ans on entend vos arguments
monsieur le Président mais pourquoi
est-ce que vous n'avez pas été compris
mais parce que une volonté d'abord parce
que je vous le dis toi sincèrement c'est
graphique on les monte depuis le début
la pédagogie
d'entendre la réalité mais je vous dis
cette réforme ça n'est pas un luxe ce
n'est pas un plaisir c'est une nécessité
pour le pays ensuite
vous pensez le président non je pense
simplement qu'il y a aussi une volonté
de passer à autre chose chez certains et
de ne pas partager cette contrainte mais
peut-on être
70% des Français
mais peut-on avoir raison seul contre
les autres de prendre ses
responsabilités dans un système
démocratique où les élections sont pas
très tardives ni celles des
parlementaires ni celle du président et
ou sur les fondamentaux d'une réforme
après il faut la compléter il faut
entendre ce qu'il se dit je vais y
revenir et je pense que beaucoup de
choses qui se sont dit ne sont pas sur
les retraites et compris les colères qui
s'expriment aujourd'hui nos pécheurs par
exemple s'exprimer Rennes c'est pas
l'air traite le cœur de leur problème
c'est des réglementation des jugements
qui leur tentent dessus bon il faut les
entendre et les aider beaucoup des
colères qui se sont exprimés ça ne sont
pas que les retraites et je veux y
revenir et pouvoir en parler on y
viendra mais notre système aujourd'hui
nous devons le réformer et donc je le
fais en responsabilité par le sens de
l'intérêt général il y a une partie des
oppositions qui ont eu le sens des
responsabilités et je vous le dis ici
aussi il faut les respecter et les
associer la majorité au Sénat n'est pas
une majorité qui soutient normalement du
président de la République
elle a enrichi ce texte elle l'a modifié
mais enfin elle a adopté quelque chose
qui va dans le même sens plusieurs élus
de l'opposition
venant de la droite républicaine ont
décidé de voter ce texte et de ne pas
voter la motion de censure il faut les
respecter c'est les associer aussi
ils ont le sens des responsabilités je
regrette qu'aucune force syndicale n'est
proposée un compromis et c'est ça aussi
il faut voir depuis le début là où
historiquement des forces syndicales
pouvaient proposer des compromis cette
page 65 ans 63 ans et demi augmenter la
durée on nous a dit aucune réforme vous
n'avez pas totalement vous n'avez commis
aucune erreur
de pas réussir à convaincre mais en même
temps je constate qu'il y a aussi une
tendance dans nos démocraties à vouloir
s'abstraire du principe de réalité et ça
c'est aussi sans doute les conséquences
d'une situation après le covid ou pour
beaucoup de nos compatriotes mais aussi
des forces politiques syndicales je note
que le secrétaire général de la CFDT
pour qui j'ai estime et respect était
allé devant son congrès en proposant
d'augmenter les durées il n'a pas été
suivi par son propre mais il avait cette
volonté de faire travailler davantage il
nous aurait proposé un compromis
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a changé les
choses on n'est plus à 65 ans en 2030
mais 64 ans et une accélération de
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
mais il n'y a pas eu de proposition de
compromis donc le compromis il a été
fait par le gouvernement après c'est
concertations il a été fait avec le
Parlement mais nous devons avancer
est-ce que c'est l'intérêt supérieur de
la nation et je vous le dis
je vous le dis en responsabilité moi je
ne cherche pas à être réélu je ne peux
pas constitutionnellement
mais entre les sondages et le court
terme et l'intérêt général du pays je
choisis l'intérêt général du pays et
s'il faut derrière endosser
l'impopularité aujourd'hui je l'entrai
alors voilà pour la pédagogie
l'explication de texte aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe dans la rue est-ce que vous
craignez un embrasement des
mobilisations un pourrissement de la
situation qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aujourd'hui à aux Français qui sont
inquiets aussi de cette situation et
qu'il a subi les ordures qui
s'amoncellent les stations essence avec
des queues considérables les blocages
d'abord je vous le dis il y a
différentes formes de contestations et
vous m'avez permis de le clarifier à
l'instant qu'il y ait des manifestations
organisées pour dire on est contre c'est
légitime
et je salue d'ailleurs l'esprit de
responsabilité de l'ensemble des
syndicats qui les dit ne pas proposer de
compromismes ont été contre avec clarté
je le respecte mais ça a été fait de
manière calme organisé le front de main
c'est normal bon à côté de ça il y a des
blocages il y a des violences les
violences il faut les condamner je l'ai
dit ni les factieux ni les factions dans
la République et il y a les blocages et
les blocages il faut pouvoir les lever
quand ils empêchent l'activité normale
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça c'est pourquoi j'ai
demandé au gouvernement d'essayer au
maximum de négocier et ensuite de
réquisitionner ce que nous avons pu
faire sur les ordures ménagères par
exemple dans certaines grandes villes où
sur les raffineries à chaque fois qu'il
faut le faire ça a commencé et ce sera
fait pour qu'il y ait pas de blocage
souvent ce sont très peu de gens
d'ailleurs un retour à la normale dans
la vie des Français un retour à l'ordre
même disait dit certains est-ce que vous
pouvez prendre un angle républicain
c'est celui que je souhaite
je prends un engagement pour ce qui
dépend de moi je suis un peu stoïcien en
la matière donc je pense qu'il faut que
il y a un chemin qui soit maintenant
trouvé et qu'on se remette autour de la
table mais
les Français commencent à se lasser on
l'entend dans nos reportages depuis le
début de semaine
on fera en sorte qu'une ville la plus
normale possible puisse reprendre face à
ceux qui bloquent à quelques-uns
l'activité et après
c'est aussi
à nous
à moi l'exécutif d'essayer d'entendre la
colère légitime qui n'est pas la
violence encore une fois mais qui s'est
exprimée au moment de ses contestations
alors c'est contestations d'abord je
vais ici rappeler qu'à chaque réforme
des retraites nous les avons et parfois
en nombre bien supérieur et
dans quelle situation serions-nous si en
1983 en 2003 en 2010 pour ne citer que
quelques-uns des exemples des réformes
précédentes ou en 2013 mais
prédécesseurs s'était arrêté devant ses
contestations en disant je fais pas la
réforme
on serait dans une situation encore plus
critique donc pour ça que je vous dis il
faut le faire maintenant
dans cette colère et ces voix qu'est-ce
qui s'est exprimé
un sentiment d'injustice et moi que
j'entends vous l'avez un peu évoqué en
parlant des entreprises tout à l'heure
ce sentiment d'injustice c'est de dire
au fond c'est toujours nous qui Bossons
à qui on demande des efforts et c'est
vrai qu'on demande cette réforme faut
pas se tromper on demande à nos
compatriotes
pour pouvoir financer la protection et
la préparation de l'avenir bon et donc
il faut entendre ce besoin de justice
moi je l'entends au moins deux égards
quand on voit des entreprises qu'on a
aidé et on continuera cette politique
pour l'entrepreneuriat pour
l'attractivité parce que ça permet de
réindustrialiser de payer nous rendre
plus fort mais il y a quand même un peu
un cynisme à l'oeuvre quand on a des
grandes entreprises qui font des revenus
tellement exceptionnels qu'ils en
arrivent à utiliser cet argent pour
racheter leur propre action là je vais
demander au gouvernement de pouvoir
travailler à une contribution
exceptionnelle pour que cet argent quand
il y a
des profits exceptionnels d'entreprises
qui sont prêts à racheter leurs propres
actions que leur travailleur puisse en
profiter donc sur les super profits non
parce que cette taxation des supers
profits nous l'avons déjà fait pour les
énergéticiens c'est ce qu'on a construit
au niveau européen c'est ce qui nous
permet d'ailleurs de financer le
bouclier face à l'augmentation de
l'énergie et c'est ce qui fait que vous
payez par moi une augmentation de 20
euros environ 20 et 30 euros sur votre
électricité votre gaz au lieu de 180 ou
200 euros ça on l'a financé en taxant
les supers profits des énergéticiens là
je dis on a des grandes entreprises qui
sont en train de racheter leurs actions
ont des contributions exceptionnelles
faut trouver la bonne technique mais
faut qu'il distribue davantage alors
salariés il faut qu'il y ait une
contribution à cet effort du moment la
deuxième chose c'est aussi beaucoup de
travailleurs disent vous nous demandez
des efforts il y a des gens qui
travaillent jamais ils ont quasiment la
même vie voyez ils ont le minimum
vieillesse c'est pour ça qu'il faut très
vite engager pour aller chercher toutes
celles et ceux qui sont au RSA et les
aider à revenir vers l'emploi les aider
et les responsabiliser et ça ce sera
dans les réformes les plus importantes à
venir c'est à dire trois et devoirs
renforcés pour les bénéficiaires du RSA
mieux les former et les accompagner
régler parfois les problèmes de logement
de garde d'enfants de transport mais
faire revenir à l'emploi des gens
aujourd'hui qui n'y sont pas parfois
depuis des années ou des dizaines
d'années au moment même où on a des
besoins c'est ce que vous avancez
que je veux qu'on ouvre parce qu'il y a
un besoin de justice à côté de ça il y a
ce qu'on entend
c'est aussi des protestations sur le
travail
beaucoup de gens à juste titre
dans l'agroalimentaire en Bretagne dans
certains métiers encore postés dans
l'industrie dans le centre de la France
les métiers aussi du soin les éboueurs
les égoutiers bon ces métiers difficiles
ils disent à 60 ans on a le doigter on
est épuisé c'est vrai mais si on est
honnête avec nous-même c'est pas 62 ou
64 ans qui est le problème le problème
il est à 55 ou 58 ans alors et donc le
vrai sujet qui a commencé à être ouvert
par le gouvernement comme par les
parlementaires dans ce texte c'est celui
de l'usure professionnelle et des fins
de carrière bah celui-ci on doit très
concrètement le prendre à bras le corps
parce que si on veut
donner quelques réponses à cette colère
légitime et une réponse efficace moi je
souhaite
il faut attendre quelques jours quelques
semaines mais qu'on réengage avec les
partenaires sociaux sur des sujets très
concrets l'usure professionnelle la
reconversion de fin de carrière il y a
beaucoup de métiers ou au fonds
du travail n'ont pas attendu la réforme
des retraites et beaucoup de choses
qu'on a fait sur les carrières
professionnelles ce sont faites durant
le premier quinquennat mais faut
continuer quand la colère s'exprime faut
aussi l'entendre et accélérer donc
l'usure professionnelle la colère
s'exprime pour non propositions
supplémentaires on a commencé à faire
les choses si j'étais là à vous dire on
a tout bien fait mais vous êtes un drôle
de type vous entendez pas qu'il y a des
gens qui protestent et ça veut dire par
là que quand ça s'exprime c'est là aussi
où une démocratie elle doit entendre la
colère légitime qui s'exprime dans un
cadre républicain et y apporter une
réponse et donc je dis
ce qu'on a commencé à apporter elles ne
sont pas suffisamment fortes et
tangibles et donc on doit aller beaucoup
plus loin l'usure professionnelle les
reconversions la deuxième chose c'est la
progression de la carrière beaucoup de
gens qui manifestent disent il y en a
qui bossent pas ce que je dis il faut y
répondre par la loi travail et le
système de droits et devoirs de
formation et d'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA mais ils nous
disent aussi au fond le travail Paypal
alors là aussi je vais vous dire on a
fait beaucoup de choses on a fait en
2019 la prime d'activités augmentait de
100 euros au niveau du SMIC jamais les
smicards n'ont autant eu leur pouvoir
d'achat augmenter depuis des décennies
on a augmenté ces 18 derniers mois le
SMIC en France de 9 et demi pour cent
plus que l'inflation
néanmoins il faut entendre ce que nous
disent nos compatriotes qui manifestent
sur ce sujet qui n'est pas celui des
retraites mais du travail qui doit payer
premièrement moi je souhaite qu'on
engage avec les partenaires sociaux dès
qu'ils seront prêts à le faire là ils
vont continuer demain de se poser mais
les invite à se réagir très vite avec
nous pour qu'on est dans toutes les
branches qui sont en dessous
du minimum légal pour leur salaire
minimum parce que vous avez des tas de
branches qui en fait continuer à payer
les gens en dessous du SMIC légal là
vous nous parlez des partenaires sociaux
avec quel partenaire politique vous
allez avancer sur ces sujets
concrets pour nos compatriotes et donc
je dis allons travailler pour mettre
l'entrée vite trouver une réponse dans
tous ces métiers qui sont insuffisamment
payés qui sont souvent les métiers de
première et deuxième ligne dont on a eu
besoin pendant la période covid et qui
continue à avoir des salaires minimum
dans leur branche qui sont inférieurs au
minimum légal et on doit accélérer
enclencher les choses deuxième élément
on doit travailler les carrières c'est
pas une loi qui changera les carrières
parce qu'on n'est pas une économie
administrée mais il faut remettre sur le
terrain
le dialogue social pour que les
carrières permettent de mieux gagner sa
vie vous savez on est l'un des pays où
le salaire minimum et des plus élevés en
Europe mais le salaire médian
c'est-à-dire le salaire en dessous
duquel il y a la moitié des gens
au-dessus duquel il y a l'autre moitié
des travailleurs c'est l'un des plus
proches du salaire minimum en Europe ce
qui fait que les carrières sont écrasées
dans notre pays et c'est un peu
désespérant pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes alors on a trouvé des
réponses on a enlevé comme vous le savez
des cotisations sociales et j'ai les
impôts sur les heures supplémentaires on
essaie mais il faut qu'on travaille des
carrières dans notre pays pour permettre
de se dire 45 50
je vais voir un progrès soit je pourrais
changer de secteur et avoir un métier
qui ne me casse plus le dos et prendre
en compte mesures soit au moins je
serais mieux payé j'aurai des tâches qui
reconnaissent mieux les choses ça c'est
du dialogue social et c'est
indispensable monsieur le Président
c'est
sur le travail c'est un sujet essentiel
on a commencé les assises du travail
mais faut rendre plus concret donc moi
je veux réengager avec les partenaires
sociaux très vite surtout ces sujets
un mois pour définir ces objets la
méthode et engager mais il faut pas des
grandes discussions et des grandes
messes discussions concrète on est tous
autour de la table vous avez commencé à
appeler les syndicats
ils vont manifester demain je respecte
cette manifestation je les engage mais
derrière ça il y a le sens du travail
moi je suis frappé et c'est pour ça que
je le dis avec il faut beaucoup de
bienveillance et de d'attention et de
patience on a eu des manifestants qui
ont dit nous on veut c'est pas la
retraite le problème on veut plus
travailler du tout
parce qu'il y a eu et on a cette crise
dans beaucoup de pays occidentaux on a
beaucoup aidé au moment du covid et donc
tout est un peu déréglé les référentiels
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est plus dur
de convaincre qu'il faut de la
responsabilité parce que pendant
plusieurs mois on a payé pour pas
travailler pour protéger le pays et on a
trouvé d'autres équilibres et donc le
rapport au travail est plus le même faut
le rebâtir et redonner aussi du sens
c'est pas des intentions sont des
engagements avec la justice de travail
avec quel gouvernement avec quelle
première ministre est-ce que Elisabeth
borne a toujours votre confiance oui
j'ai nommé Elisabeth borne elle doit
ensuite avoir la confiance du Parlement
là aussi dans institutions elle a décidé
après avoir examiné avec l'ensemble des
forces politiques de la majorité et ces
ministres pour cette réforme le fait que
pour qu'elle passe et le laisser aucune
incertitude elle a souhaité engager la
responsabilité de son gouvernement c'est
ça ce qu'on appelle le 49.3 fameux
article c'est la centième fois qu'on le
fait dans notre République c'est un
geste très solennel elle a pris ses
responsabilités avec avec son
gouvernement et elle a dit au Parlement
si vous avez une majorité alternative
qu'elle s'exprime lundi il a été montré
qu'il n'y avait pas de majorité
alternatif
à une voix près mais peut-on gouverne
pendant 4 ans avec un gouvernement croix
avec beaucoup après mais parce que
d'abord ça montre une chose même un
moment d'incandescence politique il y a
pas de majorité alternative ensuite et
donc Elisabeth borne pardon je reviens
sur la première ministre elle a votre
confiance est-ce qu'elle l'a durablement
pour plusieurs semaines pour plusieurs
mois alors elle a la ma confiance pour
conduire cette équipe gouvernementale et
ce que je lui ai demandé sur la base de
ce que je viens de vous dire et aussi du
cap des priorités on y reviendra je
pense dans le cours de notre discussion
de bâtir un programme législatif et un
programme de gouvernement en lien avec
le président de l'Assemblée et la
présidente la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et le président du Sénat que
j'ai vu hier pour avoir la fois moins de
textes de loi des textes plus courts
plus clair
pour aussi changer les choses pour nos
compatriotes de manière plus tangible
c'est tout ne passe pas par la loi et
donc dans ce contexte il faut agir au
service de nos priorités de nos
compatriotes le faire de manière très
concrète avec les élus sur le terrain
avec les services de l'État et tout ne
passe pas par la loi et on passe trop
par la loi dans notre République et
ensuite de bâtir un programme de
gouvernement pour que les choses soient
plus claires et ambitieux et apaisantes
et dans ce contexte là le mandat que je
lui ai donné c'est de continuer à
élargir cette majorité autant qu'elle le
pourra avec les femmes et les hommes de
bonne volonté qui de droite et de gauche
ou du côté de l'écologie sont prêts sur
les priorités j'ai fixées que je vais
vous rappeler et programme de
gouvernement que la première ministre va
travailler a avancer avec elle
peut-être au texte par Tex je suis pas
en train de dire qu'on peut bâtir
aujourd'hui des accords de gouvernement
de coalition on ne l'a pas fait au début
du quinquennat c'est pas notre tradition
politique
que c'est ce qu'on attendait au début du
quinquennat et ce qui n'a pas été fait
par contre il faut avoir beaucoup
d'estimes et de respect pour de nombreux
parlementaires qui
sont venus en soutien de son texte ils
étaient pas la totalité d'un participe
c'est dur de bâtir des coalitions mais
il y a des individualités politiques
avec leur conviction qui sont prêtes à
travailler avec les forces de la
majorité et donc je souhaite que la
première ministre puisse bâtir justement
cette élargissement de la majorité dans
les semaines à venir et j'espère qu'elle
n'y parvient au-delà de cet
assouplissement sur la méthode
pas de changement de Première ministre
pas de remaniement avez-vous dit il y a
quelques jours pas de dissolution pas de
référendum vous ne changez rien à la
méthode
la méthode c'est pas tout ce que vous
venez de dire ça ce sont des faits
politiques je suis en train de vous dire
en responsabilité nous devons avancer on
doit apaiser et on doit rebâtir un
agenda parlementaire et des réformes en
réengageant avec les syndicats et toutes
les forces politiques qui sont prêtes à
le faire
et donc c'est une méthode qu'on doit
réengager
avec le président du Sénat et la
présidente de l'Assemblée nous allons
réagencer les choses aussi et découper
des textes plus courts donc il y aura
bien une loi immigration il y en aura
sans doute il y aura plus sans de
plusieurs textes immigration et ils
arriveront dans les prochaines semaines
maintenant nous n'avons pas le droit
pour notre pays
à l'arrêt ou à l'immobilisme nous
n'avons pas le droit
vous savez beaucoup de nos compatriotes
aussi expriment ses peurs parce qu'ils
ont ils ont peur du changement des
grands bouleversements ce monde est
inquiétant on a un sentiment
de déclassement parfois je l'entends
celui-ci aussi quand on dit on a plus de
paracétamol nos services publics sont de
plus en plus en difficulté c'est le
réseau utilisé par Edward Philippe
l'assurance du déclassement il était à
mes côtés hier matin avec l'ensemble des
responsables de la majorité pour
justement je mener cette concertation
pour engager tout le monde
on n'a pas le droit et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'ai été lu en 2017 et
aujourd'hui mais pourquoi en sommes-nous
là
parce que pendant des décennies
nous avons habitué le pays à dépenser et
à ne plus produire ou de produire de
moins en moins nous avons entre 1980 et
2010 avant même la crise financière
détruit 2 millions d'emplois industriels
et continuer à dépenser et donc nous
avons habitué nos compatriotes à dire
tout va bien se passer on a un modèle
social formidable vous aurez de plus en
plus de droits et on va de moins en
moins produire ça ne marche pas c'est un
mensonge et donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
depuis 2017 on mène cette bataille du
plein emploi et de la
réindustrialisation c'est le cœur de la
bataille cette société du plein et on
est en train de la réussir
collectivement on est passé neuf pour
cent de chômage à 7% aujourd'hui les
plus de 50 ans dont on parle
au centre taux de chômage le plus bas
depuis plus de 15 ans et on a le taux de
chômage des jeunes le plus bas depuis
des décennies on a le taux d'activités
le plus élevé depuis qu'on le mesure et
on réindustrialise on ouvre plus
d'usines qu'on enferme ce qui est une
première depuis bien longtemps on a créé
plus des emplois industriels et on
continue d'en créer c'est le cœur de la
bataille et donc ça ça suppose de faire
quoi d'assumer les choix fiscaux qu'on a
fait pour les entreprises
si on veut continuer de réindustrialiser
il faut plus de travail et plus de
capital bon dans notre pays sur notre
sol
réindustrialiser des terres qui ont en
souffert le haut de France que je
connais bien on va y faire un des
bastions des batteries électriques pour
notre pays et notre continent
l'est de la France où on va le faire sur
l'hydrogène et sur l'énergie vous avez
etc etc donc oui on va continuer à
avancer à marche forcer pourquoi ce
bilan s'est réussi selon vous l'emploi
la Réunion d'industrialisation la baisse
sans les chiffres du chômage 7,2% le
taux de chômage exactement pourquoi les
Français ne perçoivent pas et pourquoi
sont-ils en colère d'abord je pense que
il faut toujours se méfier quand on dise
les Français
si les Français ne percevaient
absolument pas été totalement en colère
sans doute n'aurais-je pas été rééluia
moins d'un an ni une majorité relative
il y a encore moins longtemps bon donc
il y a des gens qui sont en colère que
tout ça veut dire ça veut pas dire que
tout va bien pour tout le monde il y a
des choses qui marchent faut pas qu'on
regarde simplement ce qui marche pas
mais nous venons d'une situation qui est
reposée sur une forme d'illusion et donc
là on réengage le pays se faire son
avenir et donc moi je vais continuer
d'avancer sur un cap qui est clair 1 le
plein emploi et la réindustrialisation
c'est la France de 2030 nous devons être
redevenir une grande nation de recherche
d'innovation de production sur ce point
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait avant la
réforme des retraites vous disiez
vraiment
en 2019 on peut pas demander aux gens de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans il y a 55 ans
ils ont déjà du mal à trouver du boulot
on a beaucoup repris ce passage je vais
être clair avec vous parce que j'ai le
sens justement de la démocratie et du
mandat quand je m'exprime et que je dis
ça en 2019 on a lancé les ordonnances
travail que depuis 18 mois ça fait 6 ans
maintenant qu'elles sont en oeuvre avec
les résultats que vous connaissez je
m'exprime dans une société qui est à
plus de 8% de taux de chômage le mandat
que j'ai en 2017 c'est de créer un
système universel des retraites en aucun
cas de bouger l'âge de départ parce que
le rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites et tous les experts disaient
il y a pas de problème après cette
expression que tout le monde nous
resserre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
notre pays
les gens vivaient dans quel monde on a
eu le covid on a eu la guerre on a eu
l'inflation la nation a dépensé des
dizaines de milliards d'euros pour
protéger elle a donc construit une dette
qu'on amortit dans le temps et les nos
comptes se sont dégradés au moment de la
campagne de 2022 la situation est
drastiquement différente nous avons
commencé à gagner la bataille pour le
plein emploi en baissant de deux points
le taux de chômage nous avons commencé à
réindustrialiser et donc ce à quoi je
répondais comment savoir une réponse
parce qu'on a fait tous travail et
surtout tous les experts vous avez un
problème de votre système de retraite
donc oui il faut pouvoir avancer
l'engager c'est cohérent effectivement
regardons vers le mandat que j'ai
demandé en 2022 n'était pas celui 2017
parce que le pays n'était pas le même
vous nous avez présenté plusieurs
chantiers que vous souhaitez lancer dans
les dans les mois qui dans les mois qui
viennent si on essaye d'être concret
quel sera la mesure emblématique j'ai
jamais fait la société ça marche pas
avec une mesure emblématique c'est une
cohérence
réindustrialisation pleine emploi
la France de 2030 il faut gagner la
bataille de l'industrie des carbonées
ça sera la clé le plein emploi et donc
les textes que nous allons faire passer
pour remettre au travail ceux qui sont
de plus loin de l'emploi et réussir tout
le volet travail qui va derrière le
climat deuxième cap deuxième cap l'ordre
républicain
200 brigades de gendarmerie pas besoin
de loi pour faire ça moins être ouvert
partout sur le territoire plus de juge
plus de greffiers pour juger plus vite
face à la petite délinquance réengagée
et à côté de ça une loi de programmation
militaire qui va arriver et là ça fait
partie des priorités des prochains mois
pour nos armées nous protéger ça c'est
l'ordre République et puis la troisième
priorité c'est les progrès pour mieux
vivre l'école la santé l'écologie c'est
ça les trois priorités l'école je veux
qu'elle rentrait prochaine on puisse
remplacer du jour au lendemain les profs
dans les classes des élèves ce qui est
pas le cas aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de
collèges
qu'on réponde dans la ruralité et qu'on
améliore parce qu'on a des baisses
défectifs parfois il faut fermer on
continuera de voir fermer des classes ou
des établissements mais qu'on améliore
la réponse avec parfois les écoles les
classes multiniveaux nos internats
ruraux qu'on réponde aux besoins de la
ruralité sur le scolaire qu'on réforme
le lycée professionnel indispensable
pour être juste avec nos jeunes et les
amener vers l'emploi ça fait la
formation beaucoup de chantiers qui a
beaucoup de chantiers parce qu'on a des
immenses ambitions ça c'est l'école la
santé pour cette année donner un médecin
traitant à nos compatriotes ils sont 600
000 qui sont en affection longue durée
2023 c'est le cœur de la convention
médicale de ce que le ministre prépare
qui sont qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant et qui sont dans des déserts
médicaux ils sont 600 000 qui sont en
affection longue durée ou agées et
enclencher la réforme qu'on a lancé sur
l'hôpital pour les conditions de travail
pour réengager et les déserts médicaux
et l'écologie dès les prochaines
semaines le plan o nous aurons besoin
d'avoir comme on l'a réussi tous
ensemble à gagner la bataille pour la
sobriété énergétique on doit gagner la
bataille pour la sobriété
en matière d'eau et donc tous faire une
petite part d'effort pour préserver
notre eau mieux réutiliser l'eau
de nos réseaux comme l'eau de pluie
changer les usages l'eau la forêt les
océans les transports le logement c'est
tout ça l'écologie c'est des vies
concrètes mais il faut accompagner pour
une transition juste et durable voilà le
cap
le plein emploi la réindustrialisation
l'ordre républicain est mieux vivre les
progrès avec l'école la santé et
l'écologie un mot plus personnel pour
conclure peut-être monsieur le Président
vous avez été élu en 2017 et puis l'an
dernier en 2022 avec la promesse d'être
le président de tous les Français et
d'être un rassembleur je crois même que
l'un de vos slogans lors de la dernière
élection c'était nous tous aujourd'hui
le pays paraît plus fracturé que jamais
on en a parlé vous l'avez dit vous-même
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir raté quelque chose est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir perdu le
la manière de comprendre et de parler
aux Français non je veux vous dire la
réforme qu'on fait une réforme qui est
très difficile elle est très difficile
on demande un effort aux gens c'est
jamais populaire
on n'est pas concurrencé sur le sens des
responsabilités
non plus du pas contre on est beaucoup
aidés
c'est la réalité c'était retiré la
raison bon
donc j'assume ce moment mais j'assume ce
moment parce qu'il permet les autres
et je pense que ce qu'on a fait quand
même ces derniers mois avec le Conseil
national de la Fondation un engagement
avec les territoires c'est ce que je
veux continuer moi je vois une vitalité
quand même sur le terrain je vois des
Françaises et des Français qui sont
prêts à s'unir pour avoir une réponse
concrète pour l'école pour la santé je
vois des élus locaux formidables
d'engagement et pour une mère pas de
regret
je vous le dis si j'en avais un c'était
pas réussi à voir convaincre sur la
nécessité de cette réforme qui me fait
pas plaisir une fois encore mais je dis
pas de regret moi je vis de volonté
de ténacité d'engagement parce que
j'aime notre pays nos compatriotes et
donc je suis à l'oeuvre pour pouvoir
faire ce qu'on doit faire et il y a
toujours des moments difficiles qu'il
faut assumer mais pouvoir surtout
jusqu'au bout les engager toutes et tous
pour faire ces transformations c'est pas
des lois tout ce que je vous ai dit la
plupart du temps c'est de l'engagement
collectif parce qu'on a tous une part à
prendre dans l'avenir du pays et quand
on parle d'école d'industrie de santé de
formation d'écologie
quelques jours après la sortie du
sixième rapport du GIEC on a tous une
part à donner c'est ça ce avec vous et
donc on va continuer les conseils de la
Fondation on va continuer le travail sur
le terrain c'est aussi ça cette nouvelle
méthode là c'est un texte difficile il
arrive là faut le faire mais ça ne
l'emporte pas tout merci monsieur le
Président je suis sûr qu'on saura se
finir se réunir pour l'avenir du pays
dans les coins j'en suis convaincu merci
monsieur le Président merci à vous
voilà pour cette interview 6 minutes de
questions-réponses qu'en retenir quelles
conséquence nous sommes là pour
débriefer cette interview du président
de la République va s'entraînement
bonjour directeur délégué de la
rédaction du Figaro merci d'être ici
est-ce que c'est une interview
importante qui restera et qui changera
les choses
alors qui changera les choses on fait
pas de prévision à court terme c'est une
des règles élémentaires du journalisme
important oui parce qu'elle était
attendue et que elle vient après un long
silence et à au cœur d'une crise
politique et sociale très importante
est-ce qu'elle est à la hauteur du
moment
je suis quand même hésitant c'est à dire
que
il y a à la fois de la part du président
de la République une prise en compte
contrainte de la colère légitime il a
réputé peut-être dix fois cette formule
et en même temps on sent que ceux qui
parlent vraiment lui c'est la
satisfaction du travail qu'il considère
qu'il a bien fait et de la médiocrité de
ses opposants donc
je ne je ne je ne vois pas dans cette
et dans cette intervention les éléments
d'apaisement qui étaient peut-être
attendu et je ne vois pas non plus
comment il peut restaurer l'espèce de
filtre extraordinaire qui lui avait
permis par sa capacité de conviction
d'entraînement et de séduction
non plus donc peut-être qu'on va rester
au même stade que qui a une heure c'est
à dire à avant qu'il prenne la parole
puisqu'on va en parler les annonces sont
pas extraordinaires et pas
transcendantes on a on le savait
puisqu'il c'est quand même une
intervention assez étonnante puisque
c'est une intervention le président de
la République nous avait prévenu qu'il
n'y aurait pas les éléments
qu'attendaient les gens c'est-à-dire les
trois possibilités
institutionnelles qui étaient les
référendum la dissolution où le
changement de Premier ministre
à partir de là on a eu un nouvel agenda
donc ça c'était attendu puisqu'on avait
c'est sur le site du Figaro on savait
que la loi immigration avait été
déprogrammée et puis il y a un certain
nombre d'éléments qui sont donnés très
consensuels pas très précis un peu de de
contribution supplémentaire pour les
très gros profits des entreprises et
puis quelques exigences pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA enfin il y a pas
tout ça est quand même très diffus donc
c'était son des interviews d'atmosphère
en fait c'est justement à installer une
atmosphère à quoi ça sert je veux dire
Emmanuel Macron a bien des conseillers
qui lui disent
un truc il faut prendre la parole mais
sache que demain il y aura quand même
des manifestations je suis pas persuadé
que là les gens qui regardent et qui
avaient prévu de manifester demain se
disent ah bon ben écoutez le Président
on y va pas on va pas mais si vous
voulez il y a une forme de
de pontozanes journalistique qui
consiste que l'on emprunte tous et moi
le premier qui consiste à dire quand il
y a un problème il faut que le président
parle alors on dit il faut que le
président parle et puis l'opposition
n'est pas forcément l'opposition des
faux que le président les conseillers du
mais au fait là il n'a rien à dire oui
c'est ça il n'a rien à dire parce qu'il
sait même pas comment va se terminer
l'histoire si vous voulez demain
peut-être que c'est une journée de
mobilisation qui sera une journée
d'essoufflement et qui signera la mort
lente de ce mouvement de conseils
station ou peut-être ce sera le
contraire personne aujourd'hui n'est
capable de le dire sans compter les
événements qui peuvent surgir et qui qui
viennent perturber tous tous les plans
que l'on peut avoir donc à partir de là
c'est une intervention pour répondre à
la demande de cette intervention mais la
nécessité de cette intervention à partir
du moment où il y a pas d'annonce
elle est quand même moins importante
quand Emmanuel Macron va au 20h
pour nous dire si nous allons être
confiné ou sinon nous allons être
déconfinés ou si nous serons être
cobelligérant ou pas dans la guerre en
Ukraine les Français sont devant leur
poste en se disant c'est lui qui décide
donc c'est lui qui va nous dire nous
allons là on n'est pas du tout dans ce
cadre là d'ailleurs c'est pour ça je
pense qu'il a choisi cet horaire de
mi-journée pour déjà signifier qu'on est
on était déjà dans un moment mineur une
forme de service minimum de
l'intervention politique en fait la
situation est complexe parce que il est
dans une impasse sans l'être au fond
c'est à dire que oui il y a des
manifestations oui il y a une crise bon
mais ça réformait passée
quel est son problème majeur il
bénéficie d'une constitution en titane
donc qui permet
de supporter énormément de crises et de
difficultés mais il est il est face à
des difficultés qui se cumulent la
première c'est le climat social oui
est-ce que il va réussir à l'apaiser
avec la question que tout le monde se
pose qui est est-ce que les jeunes et
notamment les étudiants et les lycéens
vont rentrer dans dans ce mouvement et à
partir de là vous connaissez la célèbre
phrase ça fait une semaine que je
cherche pour savoir si elle vient de
Jack Lang de Luc Ferry ou de Jacques
Chirac mais en tout cas elle dit les
jeunes c'est comme le dentifrice une
fois qu'il est sorti on sait plus
comment le faire rentrer en tout cas
c'est toujours pareil non elle est
attribuée selon les uns les autres bon
je vous le dirai quand je vous le dirai
quand je le saurai donc il y a ça c'est
le problème social ensuite il a un
problème parlementaire il n'a pas de
majorité il y avait cette idée de
coalition d'accords il a vu que ça
n'était pas possible donc là maintenant
on entre dans une espèce de deux de
refrain que l'on entend souvent du
cercle de l'arc central du cercle de la
raison des responsables des humanistes
vous l'appelez comme vous voulez qui
part de la gauche de Bernard Cazeneuve
et qui irait quasiment jusqu'à Éric
Ciotti bon moi
il a tenu son rang au Sénat moi je n'y
crois pas je pense que Édouard Philippe
il croit dans l'interview que vous lui
accorder ce matin et moi Philippe oui il
croit on fait mine de croire
je ne sonne pas les reins les cœurs bon
ça c'est la crise parlementaire puis
après il y a un problème politique qui
est la propre président de la République
qui est le problème de son impopularité
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a pas de point
d'appui pour dire je suis soutenu par
une majorité silencieuse qui s'irrite
des blocages parlementaires ou du climat
social dans la rue donc en fait il n'a
pas d'autre point d'appui que la
Constitution donc ça permet
de tenir Emmanuel Macron dans la
République jusqu'en 2027 parce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la première réaction
donne des personnalités politiques on
l'écoute quelques instants il s'exprime
depuis Toulouse le patron le chef de la
France insoumise
pas de grande surprise à mon avis il a
pas aimé ce qu'il a dit le président
mais écoute quand même
on y retrouve que les marques
traditionnelles du mépris dont il nous a
accablé jusque là en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que il aura mis son
imagination en grève c'est une
contribution qui est appréciée
comment peut-on alors que
le pays s'enfonce dans une impasse
comment peut-on
n'avoir pour toute réponse que de fumeux
et habituel projet pour après-demain
comment peut-on
mentir avec autant d'un regard
que comme à ces moments où il nous dit
par exemple qu'il faut tenir compte de
la pénibilité de l'usure du corps au
travail alors même qu'ils viennent de
retirer des critères de pénibilité
l'exposition
aux matières chimiques dans ce qui vient
d'être passé en force par le 49-3
comment peut-il venir dire qu'il trouve
choquant que il y ait tant d'argent
dépensé à racheter les actions des
entreprises par elles-mêmes alors même
que lorsque nous avons fait la
proposition les députés qui sont ici au
Parlement de taxer
ces mouvements de fond cela a été refusé
par son gouvernement
comment peut-il
soit de plus rappeler qu'il y a des
branches dont les minimum des salariés
sont en dessous du SMIC
dérogation à la loi qui n'est possible
que parce que lui a changé la loi
travail qui permet à l'avoir des
entreprises qui ont des accords
inférieurs à la loi comment peut-il dire
qu'il est temps de mettre ses minimum au
niveau du SMIC alors même que ce sont
ces députés et son gouvernement qui a
refusé de le faire lorsque mes camarades
qui sont ici l'ont proposé au Parlement
une fois de plus des tonnes de phrases
pour ne rien dire
offensés les braves gens qui travaillent
une fois de plus on a entendu la comédie
de ceux qui ne font rien parce que il ne
voudrait pas travailler
alors que tout le monde le sait s'il y a
6 millions de chômeurs dans ce pays ce
n'est pas parce qu'ils ne savent pas à
traverser la rue mais parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'emploi qui leur sont proposés et
une fois de plus les menaces contre les
gens qui hélas vivent au RSA
cela fait beaucoup
en si peu de mots de France
plus le temps passe et plus on a le
sentiment que cet homme vit en dehors de
toute réalité pour ensuite venir nous
dire que ce serait nous qui nous ferions
abstraction du principe de réalité
la vérité à présent et qu'il n'a rien
compris
et que ces propos méprisants pour la
foule comme il dit qu'il n'a rien à voir
avec le peuple des gentils garçons et
gentils filles qui auraient enlevé leur
bonnet pour le saluer sur son passage
la foule monsieur le président
la foule est au peuple
ce que le cri est à la voix
les foules qui s'assemble ne sont pas
des masses indistinctes de
protestataires mais des gens qui savent
clairement ce qu'ils veulent
il n'est pas vrai que cette réforme
serve à quoi que ce soit d'autre qu'à
tenir une parole imprudemment donnée à
la Commission européenne nous n'avons
aucun besoin
de remplir des caisses qui le sont
l'année dernière de 2 milliards cette
année de 3 milliards et à l'horizon de
contrairement à ce qu'il dit
l'ensemble des voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon
des tonnes de phrases pour ne rien dire
il est presque d'accord avec vous en
s'entraînement oui alors après Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a une facilité oratoire qui
fait qui se laisse emporter assez
souvent par son propre verbe donc là il
a beaucoup aussi parlé pour ne pas dire
grand-chose
non bon pour revenir à l'intervention du
président de la République
je pense que le la possibilité que cette
intervention soit décisive était très
très maigre très tout le monde avait
prévu qu'elle ne le serait pas donc il a
tenu alors après il y avait deux
possibilités au fait il y avait une
possibilité de de d'accentuer le propos
qui a été exciltré hier de la Réunion
auprès des députés sur l'illégitée
mettez de la foule
qui s'exprime à travers ses élus il y
avait où il accentué ça et donc il
accentué la crispation vis-à-vis de
l'opposition
il jouait l’apaisement et en fait il a
fait les deux c'est à dire qu'il a eu en
même temps pure voilà des comparaisons
un peu excessives il me semble avec le
Capitole puisqu'on savait pas de qui
parler si c'était les casseurs d'extrême
gauche ou les manifestants voilà voilà
et puis d'un autre côté il a répété 10
fois colère légitime
il a dit qu'il voulait parler avec les
syndicats donc les deux étaient
entremêlés si bien qu'on arrivait pas
très bien à faire le tri entre
l'apaisement et la crispation renforcée
et là encore je crois que vous parliez
de ceux qui qui sont opposés à la
réforme qui manifestent tout non je ne
pense pas que cette intervention
échanger dans leur point de vue quoi que
ce soit il a quand même refait la
pédagogue tout de suite une image c'est
une image dans les rues de Paris avec
des jeunes qui sont donc mobilisés dans
les rues de la capitale donc en effet ça
a pas empêché les gens de descendre dans
la rue non alors ils m'ont l'air quand
même assez mauvais c'est la CGT non
c'est ça donc drapeau de la Sagittaire
en effet il est possible qu'il n'est
même pas regardé considérant qu'ils
avaient déjà mais mais
plus sérieusement non je
je crois encore une fois que ça ne
changera pas l'atmosphère et que bon le
mal qui a été fait hier soir qui est
important parce que cette phrase a quand
même eu
il se trouve qu'elle se place dans une
suite de phrase qui ont participé à la
défiance un certain nombre de Français
du vis-à-vis du macronisme quel est le
problème un des problèmes du macronisme
c'est que beaucoup de gens
l'appréhendent comme une force qui se
considère avec un je ne sais quoi de
supérieur par rapport aux autres sur le
plan intellectuel et sur le plan de
l'expertise et les gens perçoivent ça
comme du mépris en disant ils nous
méprise il y a une phrase qui qui résume
tout ça c'est la pédagogie en général
quand un ministre d'Emmanuel Macron et
critiqué sur la réforme il dit on n'a
pas été assez pédagogue sous-entendu
nous sommes les professeurs les élèves
sont un peu lents à la détente mais si
on leur explique bien ils vont bien
comprendre bon et cette intervention
restaure
dans les esprits le Macron qui s'adresse
au Gaulois réfractaire Macron qui
pendant l'affaire Benalla dit venez me
chercher le président de la République
qui dit qui va emmerder les dons les non
vaccinés tout ce chapelet de petites
phrases reviennent dans les esprits donc
c'était inutile moi il me semble à
mettre une pièce de remettre une pièce
vous savez il y a une phrase de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui qui est très révélatrice
de ce que tente de faire la France
insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit il faut
tout conflictualiser et il me semble que
dans cette phrase hier soir le président
de la République et je le regrette et
rentrer dans le jeu de celui qui est
pourtant un de ses plus farouches
adversaire politique c'est-à-dire qu'il
a conflictualisé inutilement quand même
quelques instants sur ce qui s'est dit
même si
pas de grands changements attendus mais
quand même la première question portée
sur la promulgation du texte le texte a
été adopté à l'Assemblée nationale mais
maintenant il faut qu'il soit pour 1000g
alors il y a l'étape conseil
constitutionnelle qui doit valider ou
non la constitutionnalité en partie
voilà oui ou en partie vous avez raison
du texte et ensuite il faut que Emmanuel
Macron signe il a dit que il ne
lâcherait pas l'affaire et qu'il
comptait bien que cette réforme de
retraite soit active soit comment dire
il a raison au moins de 70 là il ne
reculera pas il n'attendra pas parce
qu'il y avait la jurisprudence Chirac
avec le CPE qui avait
la jurisprudence Chirac et si vous
prenez les différentes interventions de
leur dépêche Chirac mais de Dominique de
Villepin qui était premier ministre oui
je peux vous dire quels étaient
autrement martiales que celle d'Emmanuel
Macron sur le thème on ne lâchera pas on
ira puis jusqu'au moment où on lâche
mais il est évident que le Président de
la République est pour le coup puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de légit imité à toute la
légitimité pour dire le cheminement
démocratique a été fait et donc cette
loi je vais la promulguer elle sera
appliquée
ça n'est pas discutable ce qui est
discutable c'est la enfin comment dire
c'est le refus
de voir ou en tout cas en apparence que
cet agrégé à la contestation de cette
loi quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond de beaucoup plus large de
beaucoup plus préoccupant il me semble
qui qui nourrit une crise politique qui
est peut-être même une crise
démocratique et là il n'a pas mais en
choisissant dans encore une fois un
journal de mi-journée je pense que
c'était pas le lieu pour le faire il n'a
pas affiché la solennité la gravité et
l'espèce de de profondeur de vue
qu'il aurait pu avoir sur le moment sans
céder dans un président voilà et sans
céder en aucun cas sur sur sa réforme
bon quelques propositions contribution
exceptionnelles des entreprises qui font
des revenus exceptionnels oui bah donc
ça c'est enfin vous savez c'est il faut
se souvenir qu'Emmanuel Macron a un
électorat de centre droit et une
majorité de centre gauche donc dès qu'il
y a une difficulté parce qu'il a fait
une réforme qui s'apparente à la droite
sa majorité du centre gauche lui dit il
faut accélérer
donc là c'est une c'est le mode mineur
puisque ce sont les entreprises qui ont
racheté leur propre action d'autres
voudraient les super profits il y en a
même qui dirait mais est-ce qu'on
viendrait pas sur l'ISF là c'est il leur
sait ça et puis l'autre proposition
c'est le les droits et les devoirs du
bénéficiaire du RSA là c'est en même
temps donc c'est plus pour la la
part-droite pour ne pas décourager
les LR qui pourraient le rejoindre dans
cette coalition qu'il a de projet qui
dont il a tracé les contours et qui
irait de la gauche il a même parlé des
écologistes jusqu'à la droite là aussi
c'était pas tout à fait clair et précis
comme perspective politique il avait
notre question qui a été posée
évidemment l'avenir d'Elizabeth borne
alors il lui dit il le dit borne
Elizabeth borne à ma confiance mais
c'était pas franc et massif non je sais
pas si vous l'avez sorti on lui a
demandé à long terme sur plusieurs mois
et non là il répond pas bah il peut pas
s'engager non plus il veut pas avoir une
vidéo
il ne sait pas
encore une fois comment les événements
vont tourner donc là il fait comme si ça
stratégie qui est la seule qu'il puisse
avoir qui est de serrer les dents en
attendant que ça passe et que ça se
calme va fonctionner mais dans ces
cas-là il a raison aussi de ne pas
remettre en cause le fait de d'avoir
Élisabeth borne comme première ministre
bon elle est très affaiblie
politiquement d'un autre côté elle lui
est totalement acquise et c'est une
première ministre qui est docile qui lui
fait pas d'ombre il a pas beaucoup
d'alternatives voilà il a pas un banc de
touche extraordinairement fourni et il a
pas un esprit de décision dans ce genre
de de moments qui qui comment dire qui
est très rapide on a commencé on se
souvient quand même qu'il a fallu qu'un
jour pour remplacer Gérard Collomb au
ministère de l'Intérieur pour finir et
Christophe Castaner donc
cet épisode
cet épisode ancien nous montrer à la
fois que Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas
décider sur ce genre de choix et qu'en
plus il n'a pas des ressources infinies
même sans être désagréable avec Monsieur
Castaner on lui a posé des questions sur
un potentiel immobilisme désormais
puisque visiblement sa majorité relative
à l'Assemblée nationale ne lui permet
pas d'envisager sereinement les
prochaines mesures les prochaines
réformes alors peut-être de la tactique
il parle de loi plus courte plus
resserrée qu'il aurait par exemple sur
l'immigration plusieurs ça veut dire que
on fait une loi qui sera votée par la
gauche exactement une par la droite et
on avance comme ça et on avance comme ça
donc on ne fait rien de véritablement
ambitieux et rien qui ne transforme le
mouvement court donc là il y a quelque
chose de
de d'illusoir et c'est l'illusion c'est
instaurer l'illusion de de l'action il y
a une autre chose moi qui va quand même
frappé et qui qui pour le coup est
vraiment discutable et qui s'apparente à
vraiment à la politique dans ce qu'elle
est capable de dissimuler des vérités
criantes c'est quand il s'est présenté
comme une espèce de défenseur des
comptes publics qui auraient hérité de
30 ans de Gabi
et lui a le souci maintenant de revenir
à l'équilibre il faut quand même se
souvenir que c'est le quoi qu'il en
coûte qui fait galoper les déficit en
France et que au-delà même du covid
Macron a dépensé et fait des chèques
comme aucun de ses prédécesseurs et si
jamais cette réforme a eu du mal à être
acceptée par ce la même qui devait être
favorable pourquoi ben c'est parce que
c'est développé ce qu'il doit Philippe
appel dans notre interview que qu'on a
publié dans Le Figaro ce matin le deto
scepticisme c'est à dire en gros la
dette elle est déficites c'est pas grave
finalement c'est pas grave on peut vivre
avec et ça Emmanuel Macron il y a
participé et et à participer à
à faire évacuer du champ mental de la
politique et même de son parti cette
exigence est indécine c'est Eric verte
qui était sans doute le l'un des élus en
France les plus soucieux d'équilibre
budgétaire et qui a vu
les milliards donnés de depuis 3 ans
sans
renonçant au bout d'un moment assis
opposé en se disant c'est très nouvelle
c'est presque une nouvelle vérité
collective et bon bah on ne convaincra
pas les gens que un jour les déficits et
la dette ne seront portés par par nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants des
phrases à retenir ça ne me fait pas
plaisir de faire cette réforme j'aurais
pu faire comme mes prédécesseurs mettre
la poussière sous le tapis je voulais
finir Vincent avec ses grands points
alors puisqu'il faut bien donner un cap
réindustrialisation est pleine emploi
ordre républicain et le mieux vivre dans
lequel le président de la République
inclut l'école l'éducation la santé et
l'écologie bon des mais pas de mesures
qui existent l'école ça fait quand même
depuis le 2022 que l'on attend et on a
un ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
est introuvable que nous que l'on ne
voit pas
le ministre de la Santé a présenté son
plan santé je sais pas si vous en avez
écho mais ça c'est fait différent
général et je ne pourrai pas le dire
mais je pense que si on l'étudie il y a
pas plus de lit dans les services de
réanimation qu'au début du covid alors
que c'est ce qui nous a manqué
l'écologie on parle de ministre absent
l'écologie le ministre absent et puis là
il y a un problème qui
potentiellement peut déclencher des
colères sociales beaucoup plus
importantes que la réforme des retraites
c'est la dimension normative de
l'écologie notamment définie par la
Commission européenne sur les logements
et sur les voitures donc la fin des
voitures thermiques en 2035 et le fait
que 40% du parc immobilier en Europe en
2033 doit avoir été ré sinon il perdra
de la valeur et là c'est s'attaquer au
patrimoine des gens dans le lieu où ils
habitent et la voiture avec laquelle il
roule et on voit déjà que sur ces sujets
là il y a un très très fort potentiel de
colère social notamment de la classe
moyenne donc la transition écologique il
faudra aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron s'en
approche avec beaucoup beaucoup de
tactes vous pouvez voter sur Le
Figaro.fr pour la question du jour elle
est simple aujourd'hui avez-vous été
convaincu par Emmanuel Macron un centre
molette Villers oui non avez-vous été
convaincu par Emmanuel Macron
on va dire pas absolument absolument
voilà
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivi
en restant ensemble toute la journée on
sera ensemble ce soir également s'il
venait à y avoir de nouvelles
manifestations ce qui est évidemment
très probable merci beaucoup excellente
après-midi sur le figure life